hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen lektion 46 hört
zu und spricht nach
früher sollten männer keine langen haare
tragen
früher soll
männer keine langen haare tragen
früher konnten die schüler noch kein
internet nutzen
früher
die schüler noch kein internet nutzen
früher durften die frauen nicht wählen
früher
die frauen nicht wählen
die frauen den haushalt machen
früher sollten die frauen den haushalt
machen
früher
mussten alle männer militärdienst machen
früher mussten alle männer militärdienst
machen
ich wollte als kind tierärztin werden
ich musste vor dem essen meine hände
waschen
ich sollte im haushalt mithelfen
als jugendlicher wollte ich immer spät
ins bett gehen als jugendlicher wollte
ich immer spät ins bett gehen
mit 15 jahren wollte ich eine lehre als
automechaniker machen
mit 15 jahren
sollte ich eine lehre als automechaniker
machen
früher durfte man im zug rauchen
früher durfte man im zug brauchen
als ich zehn jahre alt war musste ich
immer um 19 uhr ins bett gehen
mit 18 jahren habe ich die matura
gemacht
nach dem gymnasium habe ich an der
universität studiert
nach dem studium habe ich ein praktikum
bei einer internationalen firma gemacht
ich bin nicht tierärztin geworden weil
meine eltern wollten dass ich eine
berufslehre machen
ich bin nicht tierärztin gewann
weil meine eltern wollten dass ich eine
berufslehre machen
heute ab
ich als gärtnerin
heute arbeite ich als gärtnerin
als jugendlicher durfte ich nicht aufs
gymnasium weil meine eltern wollten dass
ich eine berufslehre zum kaufmann mache
als jugendlicher durfte ich nicht aufs
gymnasium weil meine eltern wollten dass
ich eine berufslehre zum kaufmann mache
gestern war
das wetter schlecht gestern war
das wetter schlecht
ich war letzte woche krank ich war
letzte woche krank
gestern habt
monika geburtstag
gestern hatte monika geburtstag
wir waren
in den bergen
wochenende in den bergen
wie war die party
hattet ihr spaß wie
die party hatte dir spaß
warum
hier nicht an der hochzeit von oliver
und christina
warum
hier nicht an der hochzeit von oliver
und christina
wir hatten viel zu tun
wir hatten
ich hatte die grippe
ich hatte die grippe ich wollte ich war
t
test.de war
acs wollte er sie es wollte
wir
ihr wolltet ihr wolltet sie wollten sie
wollten
ich musste ich musste du musstest du
musstest er sie es musste er sie es
musste wir mussten wir mussten ihr
musstet ihr musstet sie mussten sie
mussten
ich konnte ich konnte du konntest du
konntest er sie es konnte er sie es
konnte wir konnten
wir konnten ihr konntet ihr konntet sie
konnten sie konnten
ich durfte ich durfte du
bist du
oft ist er sie es durfte
er/sie es durfte
wir durften wir durften
ihr durftet
sie durften